>>> FAME, FAME, DONALD TRUMP
SAYS HIS THIRST FOR FAME
MOTIVATED HIS RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO A NEW
EXCERPT PUBLISHED TODAY.
HABERMAN ASKED THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IF HE HAD TO DO IT ALL
OVER AGAIN, THE 2016 CAMPAIGN,
THE INVESTIGATIONS, THE
INSURRECTION, WOULD HE, TRUMP'S
ANSWER WAS CANDID AND JARRING
BUT SHE SAYS UNSURPRISING.
QUOTE, THE ANSWER IS YEAH, I
THINK SO TRUMP TOLD THE AUTHOR.
HERE'S THE WAY I LOOK AT IT.
I HAVE SO MANY RICH FRIENDS AND
NOBODY KNOWS WHO THEY ARE.
OUR REPORTERS STILL WITH US AT
THE TABLE.
I AGREE WITH THAT, IT'S JARRING
BUT GIVEN WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP OVER THE PAST
SIX OR SEVEN YEARS, NOT
SURPRISING.
>> BUT IT'S STILL A REALLY
IMPORTANT REVELATION, AND YOU
KNOW, AS I THINK SO ABOUT THIS,
I THINK THE OPPORTUNITY IN THIS
BOOK AND INCREDIBLE WORK OF
REPORTING IS TO REALLY
ILLUMINATE FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUPPORTERS OF THE PRESIDENT OR
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT THE
PRINCIPLES THAT THEY THINK THAT
HE'S CHAMPIONING AND ARE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY WANT TO
DO IN 2024, THIS IS A LOT OF
GRANULARITY AND REAL DETAIL
ABOUT HIS MOTIVATION AND WHAT HE
THINKS ABOUT.
I'M A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED THAT
THERE'S BEEN SUCH A CHOOSING OFF
OF SIDES, AND SO MANY PEOPLE
HAVE KIND OF ALREADY MADE UP
THEIR MIND.
YOU CAN'T TRUST ANYTHING THAT'S
CRITICAL ABOUT DONALD TRUMP THAT
PEOPLE WHO COULD PERHAPS BE BEST
SERVED BY READING THIS, FOR WHOM
THESE WOULD BE REVELATIONS, MAY
NOT BE OPEN TO IT.
IT IS A REAL LOOK INSIDE WHAT
MAKES HIM TICK AND AFOR SOMEBOD
WHO'S TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO IF HE'S RUNNING
IN 2024, WHETHER THEY WANT TO
BACK HIM, MIKE PENCE, NIKKI
HALEY, THIS IS INFORMATION, AND
POWERFUL INFORMATION.
>> IT'S A KEY POINT.
PEOPLE WHO FEEL SO
DISENFRANCHISED, DISILLUSIONED,
HE SAID I AM YOUR VOICE.
I WILL LISTEN TO YOU.
IN THE LEHIGH VALLEY, THERE ARE
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO THINK THE
STEEL JOBS ARE GONE, IS THERE
ANYONE WHO LISTENS TO ME AS WE
GO THROUGH THIS TRANSITION.
REFLECTING ON THE MEANING OF
HAVING BEEN PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HIS FIRST IMPULSE
WAS NOT TO MENTION PUBLIC
SERVICE OR WHAT HE THOUGHT HE
ACCOMPLISHED ONLY THAT IT
APPEARED TO BE A VEHICLE FOR
FAME AND MANY EXPERIENCES WERE
ONLY WORTH HAVING IF SOMEBODY
ELSE ENVIED THEM.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS SURPRISING
ON THE ONE HAND BECAUSE THERE'S
NOTHING THAT OR THERE ARE A FEW
THINGS THAT DONALD TRUMP LOVED
MORE THAN KIND OF BOASTING
CONSTANTLY ABOUT HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
THE FACT THAT WHILE HE'S AT HIS
OFFICE, HE HAS TIME TO
CONTEMPLATE HIS BIGGER TERM
THOUGHTS ABOUT THE PRESIDENCY
THAT IT GOES SOLELY TO HIMSELF,
AND I THINK, LIKE, ALL THE
ACTIONS THAT WE SEE, THAT IS HIS
ULTIMATE MOTIVATION, THAT
BENEFITS HIMSELF, AND WHETHER
IT'S, YOU KNOW, INACTION ON
JANUARY 6th, HIS LACK OF
ENTHUSIASM FOR, YOU KNOW,
FUNDING MIDTERM CANDIDATES OR
PICKING CANDIDATES WHO MAY NOT
BE ELECTABLE.
IT ULTIMATELY GOES BACK TO HIM
AND WHAT BENEFITS HE HAS.
>> WHICH IS WHY, TO YOUR POINT,
HE'S PLANNING ON RUNNING AGAIN
IN 2024.
WE'LL SEE IF HE ULTIMATELY DOES.
HE'S CERTAINLY PLANNING ON IT.
EVEN IF HE WANTS TO MANKE
SOMETHING UP, HE COULD HAVE MADE
UP A BETTER ANSWER.
WHICH IS NOT A SURPRISE HERE,
LIZ CHENEY SAYS IF DONALD TRUMP
IS THE NOMINEE IN 2024, SHE,
ELIZLIZ
CHENEY WILL NO LONGER BE A
REPUBLICAN.
>> WILL YOU REMAIN A REPUBLICAN
REGARDLESS OF WHAT HAPPENS IN
THE NEXT ELECTION?
>> I'M GOING TO MAKE SURE DONALD
TRUMP IS NOT THE NOMINEE, AND IF
HE IS THE NOMINEE, I WON'T BE A
REPUBLICAN.
>> SHE ALSO SAYS THIS YEAR SHE'S
WILLING TO GO OUT AND CAMPAIGN
FOR DEMOCRATS, ESSENTIALLY.
CAMPAIGN AGAINST REPUBLICANS WHO
ARE ELECTION DENIERS.
SHE MENTIONED THE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE FOR GOVERNOR OF
ARIZONA.
>> THE QUESTION IS HOW MUCH
DIFFERENCE DOES THAT MAKE.
THIS IS A PARTY THAT LEFT HER
SOME TIME AGO.
IT'S REMARKABLE TO THINK IN THIS
CONGRESS SHE WAS THE NUMBER
THREE REPUBLICAN IN THE HOUSE
GOP CONFERENCE BUT WAS REJECTED,
TAKEN OUT OF THAT POSITION
BECAUSE OF HER CRITICISM OF
DONALD TRUMP.
SHE LOST HER PRIMARY RATHER
RESOUNDINGLY THIS PAST SUMMER.
IT'S CLEAR EVEN THOUGH SHE AND
HER FAMILY REPRESENT WHAT HAS
BEEN THE ESTABLISHMENT WING OF
THE PARTY FOR SO LONG, SHE IS IN
THE VERY MINORITY OF THE PARTY
IN CALLING OUT DONALD TRUMP SO
PUBLICLY SO, YES, SHE MAY WANT
TO LEAVE THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
WE'VE SEEN OTHERS WHO HAVE LEFT
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY BECAUSE OF
DONALD TRUMP.
WILL THAT DIMINISH DONALD
TRUMP'S POWER WITHIN THE
REPUBLICAN POWER, THAT'S LESS
LIKELY.
>> IT WOULD BE INTERESTING IN
THESE COMPETITIVE RACE.
IF YOU CAN CONVINCE A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF REPUBLICANS I
CAN'T DO THIS.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE IF
IT HAPPENS.
A FRESH HMAN REPUBLICAN FROM
CONGRESS, MODELLING HERSELF
AFTER LIZ CHENEY SAID WHEN SHE
MEETS WITH FELLOW HOUSE
REPUBLICANS, IF THEY WIN THE
MAJORITY, ONE OF THE GOALS COME
JANUARY WILL BE TO IMPEACH JOE
BIDEN.
>> DO YOU EXPECT AN IMPEACHMENT
VOTE AGAINST JOE BIDEN IF
REPUBLICANS TAKE OVER THE HOUSE.
>> I BELIEVE THERE'S A LOT OF
PRESSURE ON THE REPUBLICANS TO
HAVE THAT VOTE, TO PUT THAT
LEGISLATION FORWARD, AND TO HAVE
THAT VOTE.
I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
SOME FOLKS ARE CONSIDERING.
IF THAT HAPPENS, I DO BELIEVE
IT'S DIVISIVE WHICH IS WHY I
HAVE PUSHED BACK ON IT
PERSONALLY WHEN I HEAR FOLKS
SAYING THEY'RE GOING TO FILE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT IN THE
HOUSE.
>> SHE SAYS SHE PUSHES BACK ON
IT PERSONALLY.
ONE THING THAT DID NOT COME UP
THERE FOR WHAT, IMPEACH HIM FOR
WHAT, WEARING RAYBANS IN THE
DARK?
>> HIGH CRIMES AND MISDEMEANORS,
WHICH IS AN ENORMOUSLY HIGH
THRESHOLD, THREE PRESIDENTS IN
AMERICAN HISTORY HAVE BEEN
IMPEACHED.
YOU'RE SEEING THIS IN THE AFTER
MATH OF DONALD TRUMP BEING USED
AS A WEAPON BY THE MAJORITY
PARTY.
KEVIN McCARTHY IS GOING TO BE
UNDER PRESSURE TO MOUNT THE
IMPEACHMENT ALLEGATIONS.
THERE HAVE BEEN NINE INTRODUCED
IN THE HOUSE REPUBLICAN
CONFERENCE SO FAR.
WILL HE HAVE TO DO THAT, YOU
HAVE TO MAKE PROMISES TO GO
FORWARD OR KEEP THAT OPEN IN
ORDER TO GET THE VOTES TO BECOME
SPEAKER.
>> TALKING ABOUT THE MARGINS,
YOU DON'T NEED A LOT IN A CLOSE
RACE.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT IMPEACHING
JOE BIDEN.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LIKE THE
DEMOCRATIC SPENDING.
THOSE AREN'T IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSES, FOR WHAT.
>> RIGHT.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU DON'T
SEE REPUBLICANS CAMPAIGNING ON
THIS RIGHT NOW, PARTICULARLY IN
SWING DISTRICTS.
THEY'RE SAYING I'M NOT PART OF
THE PROBLEM.
OFF OF THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL 100%.
WE KNOW ABOUT ALL OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS THAT ARE STACKED
UP.
ALL THE CALLS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
THE PLANS TO IMPEACH.
YES, OF COURSE, THIS IS LOOMING
T
, IT'S COMING.
PART OF THE REASON YOU HAVEN'T
SEEN PUSHES TO IMPEACH ALL THE
TIME, IF YOU TRY TO IMPEACH A
PRESIDENT AND YOU DON'T SUCCEED,
ALL YOU'RE DOING IS OPENING THE
FLOOD GATES TO KIND OF A
POLITICALIZATION OF THIS THING